bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir est
une écologie de l'Isère elle revient de
la vallée de la Maurienne où elle était
ce week-end pour dénoncer le projet de
tunnel ferroviaire Lyon-Turin bonsoir et
merci d'être là vous piloter le groupe
des 23 députés écolo à l'Assemblée on va
parler de votre bilan un an après
l'élection de la nouvelle Assemblée
aiguillon vert au sein de la nuque mais
avec quel succès sur le fond vous nous
le direz la nuque qui connaît pas mal de
fractures tout de même depuis un an on
en parlera mais on commence avec
l'écologie radicale ce soir la
dissolution du collectif les
soulèvements de la Terre a été prononcé
par des graisses matin en conseil des
ministres et pour Gérald Darmanin se
collectif est à l'origine de violence
répétées afin de solides notamment
contre les méga bassines dissolution
politique pour les écologistes alors y
a-t-il vraiment une menace pour la
sécurité des Français la radicalité
certaines ou des certaines la cause
climatique grand débat dans un instant
avec mes invités avant de retrouver nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris et puis
un Bourbon Express spécial en direct des
jardins de l'Hôtel de lacet au Palais
Bourbon ou la fête de la musique bat son
plein voilà pour le programme ce soir
vous me suivez Cyrielle setelain c'est
parti
[Musique]
il est devenu le mouvement emblématique
de la radicalisation de l'écologie les
soulèvements de la terre ont donc été
dissous par des créons conseils des
ministres aujourd'hui on va revenir sur
cette décision qui est à la fois
juridique très politique et même
symbolique alors l'écologie radicale
est-elle une menace dans notre pays
est-il normal on démocratie de faire
interdire un mouvement qui appelle au
sabotage et elle a désobéissance bonsoir
Florent Boudier et merci d'être là vous
êtes député renaissance de Gironde et
vous êtes le rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête sur les groupuscules violents
en manifestation qui a été créée à
l'Assemblée il y a environ 15 jours vous
débattez ce soir avec Dominique Bourg
bonsoir merci d'être la philosophe
professeur honoraires à l'Université de
Lausanne directeur de la revue la pensée
écologique et auteur de désobéir pour la
terre un titre parfaitement adapté à ce
débat c'est aux éditions PUF bonsoir
Paloma Moritz bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes journaliste vous êtes
réalisatrice également et vous êtes
responsable de l'écologie aux médias
reste auteur d'un documentaire sur les
violences policières contre les
activistes et les militants pour le
climat enfin bonsoir Antoine auberdore
merci d'être là ravi de vous retrouver
vous êtes journaliste à La Croix vous
avez enquêté sur ce collectif sur ses
origines son organisation et vous les
avez d'ailleurs suivis longuement afin
de solides dans les Deux Sèvres Cyrielle
châtelain vous y étiez vous dans la
vallée de la Maurienne on va y revenir
des écologistes dénoncent ce soir
dissolution politique dans un communiqué
vous nous direz en quoi selon vous elle
est dangereuse cette dissolution pour
vous on va commencer par planter le
décor qui sont-ils c'est soulèvement de
la terre il a deux secondes le chrono de
Blacko pour démarrer c'est parti
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir Myriam
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors en pleine
forme pour un jeudi soir pour nous
parler de ces militants
commençons par des bus ça commence fin
mars jade Darmanin c'était après les
déchaînements de violence à
Sainte-Soline c'est engagé c'était même
à l'assemblé à faire interdire donc à
dissoudre le mouvement les soulèvements
de la terre et ben depuis ce matin c'est
fait la décision était prise en conseil
des ministres explication de Livia Véran
ce n'est pas la liberté d'expression ni
la liberté de manifestation qui est en
question ce n'est pas davantage des
idées qui sont sanctionnées c'est le
recours répété à la violence
alors évidemment comme on pouvait s'y
attendre cette décision a suscité
l'indignation de l'ensemble de la gauche
et plus particulièrement de la patronne
de Europe Écologie Les Verts marines
tondeelier qui voyait disait que
Darmanin cherche à criminaliser les
écologistes donc marine pointe du doigt
de l'armadin mais il est loin d'être le
seul à criminaliser les écologistes
radicaux c'est exactement pareil en
Allemagne regardez il y a un mouvement
qui s'appelle let's generation qui a
commencé au mois d'octobre avec ses
balançant de la peinture dans les musées
sur des toiles de maître et puis qui
sait encore un petit peu radicalisé en
projetant des sabotages et aujourd'hui
donc fin mai et bien la justice
allemande a décidé de considérer à l'Est
génération comme une organisation
criminelle comme quoi il y a une vraie
radicalisation des mouvements écolos et
d'ailleurs si on venait être honnête il
y a pas que les écolos tout le monde se
radicalise un petit peu en ce moment
regardez ce que disent les sondages ça
date de ce mois-ci enfin de dernier
trimestre un tiers des Français pensent
que oui le recours à la violence est
parfois pas nécessaire pour faire
avancer ces idées donc ça dépend
évidemment beaucoup de votre orientation
politique et on remarque ce qui n'est
pas non plus une surprise que chez les
filles où on parle volontiers
d'insurrection bah voilà il y a une
majorité de sympathisants qui pensent
que parfois oui ça peut être
utile d'avoir recours à la violence
alors évidemment il y a toujours des
gens comme moi qui vont vous dire la
violence c'est pas bien et oui je sais
c'est un peu basique comme position mais
cela dit même si c'est pas bien ça peut
quand même être très efficace
souvenez-vous comment ça s'est passé à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes à la ZAD donc je
rappelle un peu d'événements il y a eu
plus de 190 décisions de justice
déposées par les indices qui ont tout
été rejetés la droite et la gauche était
d'accord sur le projet la droite c'était
Jean-Yves Le Drian président de la
Région Bretagne et dans la gauche plutôt
et la droite Bruno Retailleau présente
la région Vendée on a consulté les
habitants 55% par référendum on dit oui
on est favorable au projet et au cas où
ça n'aurait pas suffi le président de la
République lui-même avait fait une
promesse qu'on réécoute
jeune homme à médiateur parce que je
pense que ça peut faire descendre la
pression mais je le je le je le nomme
pour 6 mois maximum et à l'issue de ces
6 mois je ferai évacuer la zone avec les
forces de l'ordre qui s'imposent si on
n'a pas réussi à faire baisser la
pression
le résultat on le connaît ben il a rien
fait évacuer du tout finalement ben la
violence des adistes là emporté le
projet a été abandonné alors sachant que
les fondateurs des soulèvements de la
terre viennent de Notre-Dame-des-Landes
évidemment on se dit qu'ils ont
certainement l'intention d'employer les
mêmes méthodes pour évidemment empêcher
d'autres projets qui ne leur plaisent
pas comme par exemple le tunnel
ferroviaire Lyon Turin parce que c'est
exactement comme Notre-Dame-des-Landes
tous les recours en justice ont été et
puis j'ai on fait des sondages il y a
une très large majorité de la population
locale qui est favorable à cette liaison
d'un point de vue démocratique les
représentants du peuple et bien on va
dire ils sont il y a 59 mers dans les
métropoles lyonnaises donc 70% lance un
appel pour défendre le projet donc vous
voyez c'est exactement pareil mais
peut-être qu'effectivement si
convaincu de leur bon endroit se
mobilise par la violence ils feront
plier les pouvoirs publics mais est-ce
que ça sera vraiment une victoire pour
l'écologie je vais vous laisser débattre
mais juste avant je vous fais le petit
bémol de François Jemaine qui est
vraiment un contestable un membre du
GIEC et qui lui qui dit non non on croit
en faisant plier le gouvernement une
fois qu'on rend service à l'écologie
c'est exactement le contraire les
violences ça décourage les gens de
s'engager dans l'écologie ça donne une
très mauvaise image de cette cause le
débat est ouvert fallait-il dissoudre
les sous-vêtements de la terre merci
beaucoup Stéphane je vais commencer avec
vous Antoine auberdorff vous avez
enquêté sur ce collectif sur cette
galaxie sur cette nébuleuse et il faut
expliquer ça vient au départ de la ZAD
de Notre-Dame de landes qui sont-ils
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'il y a
très peu de structures c'est un
rassemblement d'associations c'est quoi
précisément alors il est parfois
qualifié de nébuleuse de galaxies le
gouvernement le nomme groupement de fait
en réalité ce qui s'est passé à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes en 2015 c'est la
structuration autour d'un enjeu local
environnemental avec des associations
environnementales vraiment in situ qui à
un moment donné ont été prouvé le moyen
le besoin pour des besoins opérationnels
de faire appel à d'autres structures à
d'autres forces militantes c'est là
qu'interviennent les soulèvements de la
terre c'est ce qui s'est également
produit dans le cas des bassines ou
bassines non merci était une cause le
fait de faire reculer ses retenues d'eau
qui sont qui pompent indument selon les
certains écologistes dans les nappes
phréatiques et privatise ainsi l'eau
bien bassine non merci porté par l'un de
ses faire de l'ange Julien Leguet plaidé
depuis de très nombreuses années contre
l'arrêt un moratoire sur les bassines ça
a pris un tout autre tour lorsqu'en mars
dernier et même en déjà en 2022 des
soulèvements de la terre avec un
appareil militant conséquent certes
gazeux mais militants et déterminé
arrive sur place et effectivement
obtiennent
des succès à minima de court terme par
le fait de braquer les projecteurs
médiatiques sur la problématique des
bassines ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ils ont pas structure ça n'est pas
une association vous l'avez dit c'est le
groupement de fait et un article du code
de la sécurité qui permet juridiquement
de fonder cette dissolution il dit qu'il
mérite pour une écologie sans transition
la radicalité fait partie de leur ADN
quel rapport entretiennent-ils
précisément avec la violence je pense
qu'il est important de comprendre que ce
sont des gens qui
les nanasar par exemple qui l'une des
porte-paroles des soulèvements la terre
dans un reportage absolument ce sont des
gens qui ont fait le deuil des voies
institutionnelles qui l'ère du plaidoyer
est terminée pour ces gens-là les
nanasar a participé au grève du climat
elle en a tiré un constat d'échec et
effectivement la montée en puissance de
la radicalité qui apparaît aujourd'hui
inexorable vient de ses échecs passés
c'est la raison pour laquelle sur la
violence et il faut se mettre d'accord
sur le ce qu'on entend par violence
c'est
militants c'est activistes très connu un
désarmement de ce qu'ils appellent les
structures écosystes c'est à dire des
structures qui remettent en cause nos
conditions de vie sur terre mais le
désarmement moi je l'ai lu le communiqué
de la dissolution ces choses dire c'est
quoi précisément il y a une pluralité de
tactique il y a de la résistance mais il
y a aussi du sabotage et des blocages le
désarmement pour ne pas pour éviter
des bâches d'étanchéité de manière à
mettre selon les mots des militants
encore une fois hors des tas de lumière
mais aux yeux des agriculteurs que j'ai
rencontrés sur place de bousiller leur
outil de travail pour qu'il ne puisse
plus pomper dans les nappes phréatiques
et faire remonter à l'eau à cette
surface et qu'elle soit disponible pour
l’irrigation des cultures le désarmement
c'est ni plus ni moins que ça ça donne
lieu à des bâches lacérer sur des
bassines dégradation de matériel
absolument dégradation
et alors c'est là qu'on touche la limite
c'est la ligne constante des
soulèvements de la terre que de dire que
il n'y aura jamais dans leur doctrine
d'agression des personnes physiques or
le gouvernement aujourd'hui a engagé la
dissolution sur la base effectivement
d'agressions physiques des forces de
l'ordre répéter donc c'est là tout le
problème la capacité des soulèvements de
la terre mouvement non structuré à
maîtriser éventuellement des éléments
incontrôlables en son sein qui
effectivement
on est sur une ligne de crête là parce
que on entendait Olivier Véran le
porte-paro gouvernement expliqué que
c'est pas les idées qui sont dissoutes
aujourd'hui c'est une organisation qui
aussi nébuleuse soit-elle incite
participent cautionne notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux des actions violentes il
y a des arrestations il y a des garde à
vue ça c'est sûr mais vous trouvez
justifier cette dissolution de ce
mouvement un peu multiforme d'abord il y
avait un terme de marine Tony dans le
tweet qui était montré il y a quelques
instants qui minialisation de l'écologie
ça n'est évidemment pas le sujet ça
n'est je pense que là dessus le ministre
a raison Olivier Véran sur ce point en
particulier
c'est un groupement de fait cela a été
dit donc on passe par une disposition du
code de sécurité intérieure à titre de
112-1 que nous avons révisé d'ailleurs à
l'occasion la loi séparatisme absolument
et qui vise pour parvenir à justifier en
droit cette dissolution ça fait deux
mois qu'elle aille
donner la dissolution juridique
sur les agissements violents envers les
personnes et envers les biens bon l'État
veut faire la démonstration à travers ce
décla de dissolution qu'il y a une
contribution une participation directe
indirecte à des agissements violents
contre les biens et les personnes j'ai
cru comprendre que un recours serait
porté devant le Conseil d'État et donc
on sera dans la situation d'ailleurs
allemande c'est le juge Infiné qui
décidera si oui ou non il y a eu par la
par le passé des dissolutions qui ont
été cassées par le administratif et il y
a aujourd'hui un débat qui aura lieu
entre d'un côté l'État pour vous à des
dissolutions de groupuscules
d'ultra-droites comme on a pu en voir
après la manifestation en mai comme on
peut voir aussi d'autres groupuscules
par le peste pas forcément d'ailleurs de
l'ultra-droite le CCIF par exemple après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty a été
dissous barakacity aussi tout ça ça
s'arrête à distinguer
on peut pas tout mettre dans le même
dans le même panier si j'ose dire on a
des logiques très différents des
contextes différents mais une chose qui
m'apparaît très importante qui sera sans
doute au cœur du débat ce soir la
violence en politique
est aujourd'hui un phénomène qui
s'amplifie
incite d'une certaine façon qui les
cautionne en y participant même
indirectement vous êtes d'accord avec ça
ça me semble assez décalé par rapport à
la réalité quand on va ce qui s'est
passé à Sainte Soline où il y avait deux
grenades par manifestant alors qu'on ne
baisse pas la police bien sûr ça paraît
évident mais quand vous prenez des quads
et des grenades sur la figure les choses
changent un peu en plus quand on
bombarde un cortège pacifique avec
famille et enfants apparemment par
erreur écoutez on n'est pas très sérieux
dans cette histoire déjà pour ma part il
y a un énorme problème avec le mot
violence
parce que si vous voulez la violence à
proprement parler c'est la violence
faite aux personnes et là si vous voulez
donc tout le mouvement écologique il est
très clair que ça c'est un interdit que
vous condamnez personne n'a envie de le
faire quand on regarde le communiqué et
le décret lui-même il décrit les
soulèvements de la terre notamment à
Sainte Soline en masse dernier avec des
talkie-walkies des mégaphones pour se
coordonner avec sur le terrain des
activistes qui obéit aux préconisations
de ce mouvement et armé sur armée
cocktail Molotov boule de pétanque bon
ben sans d'hier machette et j'en passe
dans la liste du décret alors attendez
premièrement si franchement notre cher
ministre était soucieux de l'ordre
public il devrait déjà dissoudre la
FNSEA
parce que ça fait des décennies qu'elle
pratique une violence contre les
personnes contre le patrimoine
sans que jamais de sanction étonnant non
donc ça déjà si vous voulez ça passe
contre les élus en plus ça passe oui
alors le sac en 99
du bureau de la ministre à l'époque
était madame Voynet bon donc non là on
est franchement pas sérieux ensuite je
voudrais rajouter deux choses non on
cherche à dissoudre une idée absolument
pas bien sûr que si mais bien sûr que si
elle est très belle puisque vous avez
l'exemple
je vous donne la parole
sur 8000 personnes il y en a 1000 qui
sont radicalisés 1000 c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a une personne sur 8 qui est présente
sur site qui est venu avec pour certains
l'idée d'en découdre physiquement avec
les forces de l'ordre et d'autres de
venir on découdre pas forcément par la
violence physique mais de participer à
un mouvement qui sera ici des violents
un sur 8 vous pouvez pas dire simplement
ça n'existe pas et vous pouvez pas
simplement régler le sujet en renvoyant
à d'autres violences commises par
d'autres organisations la violence c'est
quelque chose de relativement
dialectique j'ai manifestement c'est
relatif en effet avec une mobilisation
une telle mobilisation absurde si vous
voulez des forces de l'ordre qui a coûté
beaucoup plus cher que on aurait coûté
la réfection
de la méga machine c'est pas du tout le
sujet mais ça aurait coûté beaucoup
moins cher si vous voulez c'est ridicule
et quand vous faites ça vous incitez en
plus justement ça avait été très clair
il y avait des cortèges non violents et
il y avait un cortège oui effectivement
qui revendiquait c'est cette chose-là
après quand vous êtes quand vous
organisez une manifestation comme ça
vous la contrôlez pas totalement et en
revanche vous savez très bien que si on
vous oppose une force énorme et bien
évidemment il y aura des débordements
mais non j'aurais juste rajouter des
choses donc c'est la photo ça me gêne
beaucoup ce qui était dit sur l'aéroport
et Notre-Dame-des-Landes parce que en
fait ça a payé en fait c'est ça l'idée
derrière ce qui a vraiment payé aussi
c'était les arguments de la commission
je vous rappelle il y avait deux
arguments qu'il a fait tomber d'une part
le coup de réhabilitation de l'aéroport
avait été totalement surévalué et
l'évaluation du bruit si vous voulez
était fausse elle ne prenait pas en
compte l'évolution du groupe des avions
imaginer
que sur le lion Turin il est le même
genre de commissure
et bien je ne sais pas si on
continuerait à défendre le projet bon on
verra
rebondation qui est très limitée
c'est-à-dire qui voudrait dire que la
zatte de Notre-Dame-des-Landes c'est la
violence c'est pas ça l'ASAD c'était
quelque chose de beaucoup plus large
c'était presque un contre-projet de
société il y avait des agriculteurs il y
avait un danger il y avait des forcément
on ne blâme pas moi j'étais en Marianne
on blâme pas les gendarmes on a eu une
heure de discussion avec un commandant
de gendarmerie qui était extrêmement à
l'écoute pour trouver des solutions pour
avoir un passage et permettre qu'on
défile dans le calme c'était ça la
volontaire justement
et les équipes de nos confrères de
quotidiens y étaient aussi pour TMC ils
vous ont rencontré regardez
[Musique]
jamais eu en italien
interroger les militants n'a pas
toujours été facile vous avez
l'interdiction de manifester pourquoi on
brave l'interdiction de manifester parce
que c'est un droit de manifester c'est
un droit fondamental
allez la bouche allez la vidéo
doucement voilà journaliste terroriste
vous étiez mal à l'aise on le voit
clairement et d'ailleurs
au moment où je leur dis c'est dommage
parce que pour moi justement la liberté
de la presse c'est le barrage contre le
fascisme donc là j'étais profondément
désaccord mais c'était pas le sujet de
cette manifestation il y avait plusieurs
milliers de personnes mais ça plante
quand même à le décor
dans une manifestation de tous les
slogans de toutes les manifs j'ai fait
très nombreuses manifestations ce qui
nous rassemble c'est un mot d'ordre et
là le mot d'ordre il était simple
c'était non un projet qui est
aujourd'hui climaticide qui va
artificialiser 1500 hectares de terre
naturelle et agricoles et qui va les
drainer l'eau pour aller fracturer la
montagne c'était démocratique c'est ça
l'enjeu aussi mais la question c'est
pour le moment il a été accepté validé
discuter le débat démocratique et en
vrai quand même moi je suis très mal
présenté parce qu'on nous dit c'est les
camions ou le rail et moi je suis pour
le rail on dit pas aux par contre quand
vous le mettez sur l'oreille est-ce que
vous voulez moderniser la ligne
existante ou faire un nouveau projet qui
va avoir des impacts colossaux en termes
environnemental qui va coûter 30
milliards d'euros qui va empêcher de
faire d'autres rénovations et qui en
plus sera prêt en 2032 pour le tunnel de
base et en 2045 pour le reste du projet
ça on le dit jamais c'est à dire qu'on
dit le camion ou le faire mais on va le
rail tout de suite on va faire débat
sûrement voilà pas aujourd'hui sur Lyon
Turin mais c'était bien d'en parler allô
maman il est aussi politique ce débat il
est juridique mais il y a aussi des
arrière-pensées politiques Gérald
Darmanin il incarne l'ordre c'est le
ministère de l'Intérieur il avait dit ça
au lendemain de Sainte-Soline lors d'une
conférence de presse regardez
une quarantaine de personnes fiches à
l'ultra gauche ont été repérés dans
cette manifestation avec des modes
opératoires qui relèvent je n'ai pas
peur de le dire de l'éco-terrorisme que
nous devons absolument combattre voilà
c'est un mot qui la réutilisé dans le
Journal du Dimanche et c'est en fait
c'est un mot extrêmement choquant parce
que parler des côtes terrorisme c'est
une gifle au visage de toutes les vrais
victimes de terrorisme et en fait on
voit aujourd'hui qu'il y a à la fois une
criminalisation des maisons écologistes
et je n'ai pas peur d'utiliser ce mot
par les mots c'est à dire en les
traitant des côtes terroristes de
mervères d'ayatollaher ou autre mais
aussi par l'action de l'État c'est à
dire que on voit que depuis 2015 il y a
vraiment une escalade répressive de
l'État qui a commencé en fait avec
l'état d'urgence c'est à dire qu'il est
arrivé au moment de des manifestations
pour la cop21 on avait la COP 21 à Paris
et on a eu et en fait toutes les mesures
qui devaient lutter contre les salisses
l'islamisme radical et le terrorisme on
trouvait comme premier application les
militants écologistes qui ont été
assignés à résidence ou qui ont été
interdits de manifester et depuis en
fait la loi n'a fait qu’évoluer et à
chaque fois quand on voulait lutter
contre le terrorisme la loi séparatisme
le but de la loi séparatisme au début
c'était de lutter contre le terrorisme
et on voit en fait que c'est en vertu de
la Loi et c'est en vertu d'aller à
l'ouest je sais je peux terminer c'est
en vertu la loi séparatisme que les
soulèvements de la terre ont été dissous
et du nouvel disposition du code
intérieur et c'est exactement la même
chose avec le contrat d'engagement
républicain aujourd'hui on a des
associations écologistes dont on on va
menacer leur subventions en vertu de ce
contrat je vais vous renvoie en fait que
on a un arsenal juridique policier
administrative qui est de plus en plus
important et ce qui est dommage parce
que vous parliez de question
démocratique c'est que justement au lieu
d'écouter les alertes des militants
écologistes parce qu'il y a quelque
chose je pense qu'il faut rappeler ce
soir c'est que il y a peu de temps par
l'urgence de la situation c'est de dire
comment est-ce qu'on crée un dialogue
comment est-ce que en fait on va
s'accorder pour un nouveau projet de
société qui va nous permettre d'avoir
des conditions de vie habitable mais ce
mot là que vous avez condamné qui est
très politique des Caux terrorisme je
voudrais quand même vous soumettre ce
qui se passe en Provence à Bouc-Bel-Air
vous avez vu les très gros dégâts contre
le cimentier Lafarge ce sont des dérives
terroristes qui sont là je pèse les mots
redouté par le gouvernement les services
antiterroriste qui sont mobilisés
dans le cas des soulèvements de la terre
ils sont mobilisés et vous avez parmi
les inspirateurs je vous prête la
contradiction vous êtes là pour débattre
un Suédois qui s'appelle Andres Malm qui
appelle ouvertement dont on dit que
c'est l'inspirateur de ces mouvements de
soulèvement de la terre à dépassé le
pacifisme je le cite et usé de tous les
moyens pour abattre le capitalisme
responsable de la catastrophe écologique
ce genre de discours là vous la
militante
je suis journaliste la journaliste vous
avez aussi une cause à défendre et c'est
totalement légitime même quand on est
journaliste
ça nous concerne absolument absolument
vivre une canicule enfin je pense en
fait que là encore il faut revenir sur
le terme de violence et les moyens
d'action aujourd'hui on a une situation
qui est de plus en plus grave on le voit
absolument partout on va bientôt avoir
une canicule récemment il y a une étude
qui est sortie qui montre que la planète
menace de devenir inhabitable ce genre
de discours là est-ce que vous par
rapport à ça on connaît vos distances et
de dire bah par rapport à l'appréciation
de la gravité de la situation que l'on a
on ne va pas apprécier de la même
manière les modalités d'action quand on
voit que les mi-temps écologistes ont
absolument épuisé tous les recours pour
se faire entendre et bien
potentiellement oui à un moment ils vont
avoir d'autres recours qui vont être des
dégradations matérielles parce qu'encore
une fois il y a aucun aucune violence
qui est appelée envers
séparatisme il y a aucune mesure sur le
terrorisme aucune j'en étais le
rapporteur je connais le texte Parker
c'était la laïcité l'islamisme
éventuellement politique rien il y a pas
une ligne une loi qui permet une ligne
sur
il n'y a aucune ligne sur les menaces
touristes et ensuite votre discours
pardon de vous le dire on ne se connaît
pas donc première rencontre elle sera
désagréable et toutes mes excuses
enchanté
moi je considère que votre discours est
une forme de légitimation évidente
manifeste de la violence alors vous
dites une fois que les recours
juridiques par conséquent une fois que
les scrutins électoraux sont passés et
que l'on a le sentiment d'un empêchement
agir ou d'aboutir et d'atteindre
l'objectif que l'on souhaite atteindre
la cause environnementale en particulier
alors si ça ne fonctionne pas oui la
violence est possible par les
dégradation matérielle mais il faut
imaginer je termine là-dessus après je
laisserai la parole si vous permettez il
faut imaginer comment certaines nos
concitoyens prennent cette parole
certains d'entre eux le prennent au pied
de la lettre madame et considère qu'en
effet s'il y a une un empêchement d'agir
si par exemple la majorité n'est pas la
leur politique si le juge n'a pas décidé
tel qu'il le souhaite alors maintenant
j'ai des élus j'ai des journalistes j'ai
des députés parfois et je ne parle pas
de vous un président évidemment je
connais vos déclarations
c'est ce que je viens de dire est une
solution et qu'elle est au fond
acceptable ça je pense que c'est
extrêmement dangereux et vous avez eu
tout à l'heure je tourne monsieur bourg
en l'occurrence vous avez des propos qui
me semblaient eux aussi d'une certaine
façon
être à la très grande limite de
l'incitation à la violence ensuite il y
a cette question qu'est-ce que la
violence
Dominique Bourg personne au verre d'or
et ensuite je vous montrerai quand même
la réaction des soulèvements de la terre
parce qu'ils ont des portes on peut
mettre la vie sur Terre Dominique Bourg
façon très ferme je vous dis tout de
suite André asmalm
franchement
je n'éprouve pas beaucoup de sympathie
pour ce genre de posture et je renvoie
les auditeurs les auditrices un très bon
article d'un journaliste du journal des
croissants qui s'appelle Pierre tessey
alors là vous allez voir c'est une
critique ou vitriol que je partage de A
à Z dans certaines conditions la
violence a conduit à sélectionner les
pires maintenant on voit très bien entre
nous que la violence c'est quelque chose
de relativement métaphorique chaque fois
qu'on emploie le mot personne ne met le
même sens et on ne peut pas isoler la
violence si vous voulez du cadre général
dans lequel on s'exprime vous avez un
gouvernement qui s'est engagé à baisser
de 4% ses émissions des émissions
nationales au terme de la loi en fait
cette année c'est moins d'un pour cent
ça c'est une extrême violence quand vous
connaissez le dossier scientifique alors
évidemment c'est pas monsieur Darmanin
qui le connaît vraiment bien c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire quand vous savez
exactement la violence de l'inaction
l'inaction des pouvoirs publics c'est
une espèce de démission par rapport à la
fonction première qui est la leur qui
d'assurer la sécurité
soulèvements de la terre finalement les
citoyens et d'agir réellement Antoine
oberdin
que je connaisse en tant que journaliste
en tout cas pour dépasser la violence
l'instrumentalisation de la violence par
les uns par les autres le fait de
renvoyer FNSEA et Confédération paysanne
dosado c'est de retourner sur le terrain
et s'apercevoir que dans les Deux-Sèvres
par exemple dans le marais poitevin on a
affaire à des acteurs qui sont pris en
étau totalement avec d'une part des des
militants du collectif merci qui je
pense et de fne17 qui sont sincèrement
inquiets pour l'état du Marais Poitevin
la dégradation de la biodiversité et par
ailleurs des gens qui le fréquentaient y
compris étant gamin dans cette région
magnifique des Deux-Sèvres à qui il ne
parle plus parce que ce sont des
agriculteurs qui eux-mêmes se demandent
ce qu'ils ont fait parce que étant
agriculteur irigans il y a aussi des
éleveurs chevriers par exemple qui ne
comprennent pas pourquoi ils sont pris
pour cibles aujourd'hui et la question
c'est sortir du face-à-face exactement
alors on va quand même les entendre les
soulèvements de la terre on disait que
c'était gazeux qui avait pas de
structure pas de bureau pas de
financement en tout cas officiel et
pourtant ils ont des porte-paroles c'est
Clément Pergaud qui les a rencontrés
reportage
Lena Lazare est l'une des portes-parles
des soulèvements de la terre pour elle
le gouvernement cherche d'abord à
criminaliser l'écologie radicale on
s'attaque pas du tout à un mouvement qui
est comme souhaite le dire le ministère
de l'Intérieur un groupe muscul d'ultra
gauche violent etc on mène des actions
désobéissance civiles impactantes mais
elles ont toujours fait partie
des palettes d'action des mouvements
sociaux
des actions de désobéissance civile
impactante qui ont tourné aux
affrontements violents avec les forces
de l'ordre comme ici à Sainte-Soline au
mois de mars en opposition à un projet
de méga bassine agricole
tout accusation de violence dans le sens
où en effet on a eu des manifestations
où il y a une partie des manifestants
Harry poster de manière violente
au dispositif policier après pour moi
c'est quelque chose qu'on observe dans
toutes les grandes manifestations ces
dernières années s'ils assurent ne pas
appeler à la violence physique contre
les personnes les membres des
soulèvements de la terre estiment que
l'urgence climatique justifie une
certaine radicalité toute la grande
victoire qui ont eu les mouvements
sociaux ça passait par des actions qui
étaient illégales qui sortaient du cadre
qu'on donnait que donner l'état à la
contestation les militants écologistes
ils ont essayé beaucoup de choses on a
fait des manifestations massives on a
fait des recours en justice on a fait
d'autres actions désobéissance civiles
qui est peut-être été jugées moins
offensive mais on voit que
la voix institutionnelle elles sont
totalement bouchées et que là on a du
mal à faire en sorte que le gouvernement
agisse réellement
Henri post à cette dissolution les
soulèvements de la terre ont appelé à
des rassemblements ce soir un peu
partout en France il compte aussi
déposer des recours judiciaires et se
disent prêts à saisir la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme
c'est incroyable la jeunesse de ses
paroles ça fait partie de la stratégie
c'est je crois pas que ça soit tellement
une stratégie en tout cas concertée
effectivement les nanas du Tertre sont
tous extrêmement jeunes mais comme je le
disais précédemment
c'est la génération climat qui s'est
investie dans les grèves du climat qui
qui a été plein d'espoir au moment de
l'affaire du siècle et qui qui a des
chanté qui a des chanté très clairement
d'ailleurs
sur la voie juridique et j'avais
l'occasion d'en parler avec des avocats
encore aujourd'hui elle demeure très
intéressante pourquoi au mois de mars Au
mois de janvier dernier pardon des
procès en puisse tenir avec des
militants écologistes à La Rochelle et
Niort ça a donné lieu à des
mobilisations de la terre de bassine non
merci et un véritable débat
contradictoire à prix place
grâce au Sénat dans le cadre judiciaire
le tribunal absolument avec des
magistrats qui ont joué le jeu et qui
manier cette notion juridique encore à
définir des tas de nécessité écologiques
c'est-à-dire la capacité que l'on se
donne à agir y compris éligible
au fond est-ce que c'est pas ça le lieu
de la maïeutique pour sortir du face à
face ces débats judiciaires dans le
cadre de plainte plutôt qu'une
dissolution en fait les soulèvements de
la terre j'ai regardé c'est un texte si
on doit les définir c'est un texte nous
sommes les soulèvements de la terre
rédigés en 2021 par on l'a dit les
historiques de Notre-Dame-des-Landes ça
avait recueilli sans dix mille
signatures il y a toutes sortes de gens
des particuliers des syndicats des
chercheurs il y a même l'écrivain Alain
Damasio l'écrivain de science-fiction on
peut dissoudre des gens ce que c'est
est-ce que vous croyez pas qu'il va y
avoir ce qu'ils appellent déjà une
repousse sous un autre nom dès ce soir
premièrement la dissolution d'un
groupement de fait par définition elle
l'aboutit pas à un impact immédiat les
gens existent toujours et leur mode
d'action aussi et personne n'est naïve
ce monde mais ce que recherche l'État à
travers une dissolution notamment d'un
groupement de fait au fond c'est une
forme de déstabilisation de celles et
ceux qui sont entrés dans une phase que
j'estime pour ma part violente et pas
tous certains d'entre eux les plus
radicalisés des radicalisés
déstabilisations faire en sorte que il y
ait aussi un débat en interne entre ceux
qui considèrent que la voie de la
violence et légitime et celles et ceux
qui considèrent que il faut s'interroger
et que c'est peut-être une ligne de
partage qu'il faut réinstaller je
termine sur un point moi je suis
extrêmement inquiet quand j'entends cela
je ne parle pas de la cause elle-même et
je ne parle pas de la notion d'état de
nécessité et je ne dément pas ce qui a
été dit sur l'urgence agir je suis
député puis je suis citoyen aussi et
j'ai les deux casquettes mais j'entends
dans le pays deux types de pour qui me
semble très dangereux il y a ceux qui
basaient sur un discours
environnementaliste je ne parle pas de
l'écologie politique
disent il faut aller plus loin dans la
violence et puis il y a une partie très
radicalisée aussi qui est un discours
immigrationniste et qui a le même
discours en disant la France est envahie
elle est au bord de la submersion et par
conséquent il faut la violence moi c'est
ultra là c'est ultra là je les trouve
dangereux pour la démocratie et au fond
en tant que député je pense que si elle
est châtain va être d'accord avec moi
sur ce point je trouve que c'est d'abord
et avant tout l'échec du politique
je vais vous donner vraiment chacun mais
très très rapidement la parole j'ai une
question pour vous quand on utilise les
voix légales par exemple le la
condamnation de la France pour une
action climatique Corinne Lepage le
maire de Grande-Synthe il y a plein
plein de choses qui ont été faites pour
vous est-ce que c'est plus efficace
que cette voix des soulèvements de la
terre mais il faut les deux et
d'ailleurs il y a des personnes qui ont
contribué à recours juridique qui sont
également membres des sauver le monde de
la terre et je voudrais juste revenir
pour vous c'était non et c'est même en
fait c'est des mouvements qui se
connaissent qui se parlent et qui
agissent ensemble et pour répondre moi
je pense que la cette question de la
nécessité pourquoi est-ce qu'on appelle
soulèvement parce que soulèvement c'est
100000 personnes c'est 100 000 personnes
je les soulèvement de la terre ça sera
sans doute bien plus la question pour
revenir peut-être l'introduction je
crois à la force du nombre je crois la
force du nombre et je crois
effectivement que c'est par le violence
vous avez 10 secondes chacun on explose
les temps pour conclure ce débat est
magnifique et l'exprime un état d'esprit
un état d'esprit ça ne se dissout pas en
essayant de le réprimer on va le
développer merci Monsieur Darmanin
qui augmente en Europe et sur laquelle
les experts de l'ONU ont alerté le 15
juin dernier en disant qu'il y avait une
criminalisation et une répression de
plus en plus forte envers les militants
écologistes et c'est quelque chose qui
doit nous inquiéter sur les têtes d'un
démocratie en Europe et en France bon
merci beaucoup on va s'arrêter là vous
étiez un peu en minorité je le confe en
fait ce soir mais c'était passionnant de
vous écouter on aurait pu continuer
longtemps vous restez avec moi Cyrielle
châtelain dans une dizaine de minutes
les parties pris de nos affranchies ce
soir la féministe Léa chamboncet lance
un avis de recherche où est passé la
proposition de loi sur l'inscription de
l'IVG dans la Constitution pourtant
voter ici au Palais Bourbon et puis
Thomas l'estavel va ouvrir le catalogue
des technosolutions ça va vous faire
réagir c'est rien de châtelain ce soir
la captation de CO2 sous la mer et puis
un Bourbon Express ce soir où êtes-vous
Valérie Brochard
[Musique]
de la scène pour la fête de la musique
évidemment on en parle tout à l'heure
merci à tout à l'heure Valérie on parle
de vous et de votre groupe à présent
Cyrielle châtelain ça fait un an pile
que vous pilotez ces 23 députés écolo à
l'Assemblée au sein de la nupes comment
avez-vous pesé quels sont vos victoires
et vos échecs on voit cela dans
l'invitation signer ce soir par
Stéphanie Despierres merci à vous
si on vous invite Cyrielle Chaplin c'est
pour faire le bilan du groupe écologiste
à l'Assemblée membre de la nupes tout
juste élu député de l'Isère vous prenez
les reines du groupe en duo avec le
Parisien Julien Bayou après sa mise en
retrait en septembre vous restez seul
aux commandes encarter à 18 ans cadre
dans des collectivités locales
spécialistes du logement vous décrochez
un premier mandat l'année dernière vous
dirigez 23 députés avec des
personnalités qui font le buzz comme
Sandrine Rousseau y compris contre son
propre camp lorsqu'elle déclenche
l'affaire Bayou qui fera pshit à
l'automne serial châtelain madame la
Première ministre vous défendez la
motion de son sur déposée par la nupes
après le premier 49 3 d'Elizabeth borne
sur le budget nous ne laisserons rien
proposeront et nous proposerons encore
la taxe sur les super copie une fexe
qualité qui intègre le principe pollueur
payeur la création d'un ISF climatique
cette année votre groupe a
systématiquement voté contre tous les
projets du gouvernement sur le nucléaire
évidemment mais aussi sur les énergies
renouvelables vous vous êtes abstenu cet
hiver pendant la bataille des retraites
vous jouez collectif avec la nupesse
l'unité dans la rue l'unité à
l'Assemblée nationale sachez que chacune
des heures chacun des jours sera dédié à
démonter les fausses informations du
gouvernement mais le débat n'avance pas
le chahut dans l'hémicycle les
provocations les insultes ce n'est pas
votre genre les divergences de
stratégies avec les insoumis sont de
plus en plus visibles au dernier jour
des discussions vous jetez un pavé dans
la nupesse dans une interview vous
fustigez un raté stratégique de la
France insoumise un raté qui n'a pas
permis selon vous d'avoir un vote sur
l'article 7 celui sur les 64 ans
la bataille des retraites a laissé des
traces dans la nupesse elle devrait se
fissurer un peu plus avec les
Européennes de 2024 chacun fait cavalier
seul vous ne voulez pas de liste commune
les communistes n'ont plus alors
Cyrielle chapelain n'est-ce pas le signe
que cette alliance est en péril réponse
non absolument pas alors oui on a eu des
désaccords des désaccords tactiques
pendant la réforme des retraites nous on
voulait aller à l'article 7 on pensait
qu'il fallait aller à ce débat et
potentiellement potentiellement même
aller au vote je pense qu'on aurait une
part de responsabilité alors déjà je
pense que ça faisait débat même chez eux
mais Montreux et que cette question là
en tout cas la question les
mélenchonistes de l'Assemblée mais en
tout cas la question qui nous animait
tous à ce moment-là c'était comment
représenter au mieux à l'Assemblée le
mouvement qui avait dans la rue on a
conscience de l'ampleur de cette réforme
de l'impact qui va sur la vie des gens
nous pensons que c'était en ayant le
débat eux ils pensaient que c'était en
ne lâchant rien point et en ne
permettant pas par qu'un coup d'éclat il
puisse obtenir un vote qui permettrait
légitime avait perdu quelque chose oui
mais nous on a on a enlevé nos
amendements on a été c'est ça la nupes
on est on chacun on se parle on
construit des choses et après s'il y a
des moments de désaccord chacun suis sa
stratégie nous avons enlevé nos
amendements le PS enlever ses
amendements le PC enlever ses
amendements et oui on a eu un désaccord
on s'en est d'accord qu'on a été
ponctuel prix ponctuel dites-vous sur
les retraites vous l'avez assumé alors
ponctuelle aussi sur les européennes
vous savez ce que disait Mathilde panot
à votre place il y a quelques jours elle
disait que si la nuque pèse faisait
cause commune aux européennes tous les
sondages le montrent la nupes arrive en
tête devant le RN les derniers sondages
la mettent à 27% sacrées quand même une
sacrée dynamique à gauche non mais moi
je pense que la dynamique à gauche c'est
d'envoyer le plus de parlementaires
européens siégé en Europe pour faire
face à la droite et à l'extrême droite
européenne aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir des
listes qui représentent chacune les
différentes identités de la gaucher des
écologistes qui permettent par contre là
on doit continuer et on fait notre
travail commun toujours à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est de construire un projet
pour 2027 et je pense que c'est force là
qu'on va aller puiser chacun alors après
c'est parti aussi des projets mais pour
2020 c'est bien sûr mais est-ce qu'il y
a de gauche sur l'Europe encore
aujourd'hui il n'a pas nouveau chez
réconciliables sur l'Europe la preuve
par exemple le travail qu'on a fait sur
la loi de programmation militaire soit
de programmation militaire chacun
défendu ses positions et on a réussi à
travailler des amendes nom commun avec
le chef de fil et les filles et la chef
de fil du PS pour par exemple travailler
sur l'augmentation des coopérations avec
les autres c'est pas exactement la même
chose la question européenne même si ça
y participe et parce que la loi de
programmation
militaire c'était l'Europe de la défense
oui et donc c'est sur ce sujet là
justement c'est sur les coopérations
européennes en matière de défense en
matière d'industrie militaire qu'on
arrive à avancer et la position sur la
Russie sur Poutine des critiques des
traités
c'est sur ça qu'on vous dit c'est la
question de la coalition chacun des font
ces points de vue et après on construit
du commun on construit des positions
communes et c'est pour ça que je pense
dès qu'on a un désaccord on parle de
fragilité moi je pense aujourd'hui d'une
démocratie mature comme ça se fait donc
chez tous nos collègues européens on
assume nos différences et on monte
démocratiquement nous on arrive à
construire des solutions vous auriez pu
en construire aux européennes avec les
socialistes pourquoi vous les acceptez
pas dans une liste commune c'est pas une
question d'accepter là vous pensez
pareil sur l'Europe la question
aujourd'hui nous on porte une liste
écologiste parce qu'on pense qu'on a un
message écologiste sur l'Europe et moi
ce que je pensais que chacun doit
pouvoir porter son message et surtout on
doit dire mais en fait si vous vous êtes
reconnu parmi nous aux européennes nous
aurons un seul candidat ou une seule
candidate en 2027 et on vous amène à
voter pour nous pour changer notre chef
de fil qui sera chef de fil et les
écologistes auto européenne alors ça on
le saura bientôt sans doute mi-juillet
on a deux candidats David Corman Marie
Toussaint voilà ça va être décidé
démocratie interne ça reste une marque
de fabrique tout à fait c'est facile de
piloter ce groupe écolo aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est facile de faire
cohabiter par exemple Sandrine Rousseau
et Julien Baillot aujourd'hui mais en
tout cas c'est il y a quelque chose
d'une évidence chez nous c'est qu'en
fait on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur on
n'a pas le droit à l'erreur parce que le
débat qu'on vient d'avoir montre
l'urgence du moment et en fait quel que
soit les divers les mêmes les désaccords
qu'on peut avoir les les désaccords
interpers
entre eux mais en fait la question c'est
on travaille ensemble on travaille
ensemble parce qu'on a le même objectif
et en fait ces questions là aujourd'hui
nous à l'Assemblée nationale la question
c'est tracer la voix et de dire à toutes
les personnes qui s'inquiètent pour leur
avenir par rapport échauffement
climatique nous sommes là nous nous
battons on va pas y passer trop de temps
mais quand même est-ce que vous
regrettez
ce qu'a fait au Sandrine Rousseau dans
l'affaire Bayo est-ce qu'elle a commis
une faute elle ne regrette rien
des propos qu'elle a tenu sur le plateau
de c'est à VOUS accusant de violences ou
de harcèlement plutôt psychologique de
Julien Bayou à l'encontre d'une ancienne
campagne compagne pardonnez-moi ça ça
laisse des traces ou pas aujourd'hui on
en a beaucoup débattus ça a pris des
semaines du temps qu'on a nous pour
travailler on dit aujourd'hui en fait
cette question elle est non mais on a un
groupe qui fonctionne on me répondait
pas mais c'est pas grave est-ce que je
vois pas déterrer les débats dire un an
on déterre pas on avance fonctionne vous
êtes pas tendre avec le gouvernement qui
a quand même repris l'idée de
planification écologique que vous
défendiez il parle des hommes désormais
d'adaptation au réchauffement climatique
vous en parlez de sobriété ça n'est plus
un gros mot il va mettre des milliards
sur la table dans le cadre de France
2030 pour investir massivement dans la
transition
tout ça c'est pas bien
par exemple prenons l'exemple de la
planification aujourd'hui la
planification revient enfin Elisabeth
borne l'a présenté donc c'était plutôt
un état des lieux moi j'appelle ça un
état des lieux parce qu'une
planification ça donne des objectifs et
ça donne des moyens pour l'atteindre au
même moment on a le décret qui sort sur
l'interdiction des liaisons intérieures
il y en a trois qui sont interdites 3 la
convention pour citoyens pour le climat
c'était les vols s'il y avait une
alternative 4 heures là c'est trois
liaisons interdites 2h30 seulement mais
c'est même pas 2h30 c'est qu'on a trouvé
le moyen de ces deux heures et demie de
regarder comment on pouvait impacter le
moins possible le déplacement aérien ou
un autre exemple il y a encore une
semaine on a voté une autoroute qui fait
16 km en Savoie enfin ça fonctionne pas
c'est à dire qu'en fait il y a des mots
il y a que des mots d'hypocrisie pour
vous si
sur la question environnementale de la
part du gouvernement moi c'est ça que je
constate franchement mais 2030 2030 pour
réduire drastiquement nos émissions de
gaz à effet nécessaire en fait on a plus
le temps de se payer le mot
industriaire l'idée de ramener des
usines pour construire par exemple dans
l'hydrogène pour les énergies vertes le
soleil l'éolien offshore les batteries
électriques ça va pas dans le bon et
nous on est favorable à les
industrialisation parce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui être face à l'impact
environnemental de nos modes de vie par
contre il faut aller de sur la vous
parliez de sobriété quels sont les
objectifs en termes de réduction des
impacts en eau quelles sont les
impacts ton père comment on fait sur les
minerais et tous les minéraux rares
enfin c'est cette question là qui sont
au cœur du débat sur l'industrie verte
elles ne sont pas dans le projet de loi
et il manque un volet consommation
c'est-à-dire que oui pour
réindustrialiser par contre on doit
poser la question de de quoi a-t-on
besoin est-ce qu'on a besoin pour
continuer à faire fonctionner cette
machine à consommer d'avoir des outils
dont la qualité dégradée pour faire de
l'obsolescence programmée donc moi je
pense que
rendez-vous de l'hémicycle vous pourriez
voter mais on aura beaucoup de
propositions bien Charles notre chef de
fil va sortir un manifeste sur la
question de la réindustrialisation oui
on a besoin de penser comment on produit
comment on produit dans le respect de
nos limites planétaires et on verra ça
et vous reviendrez pour parler de ce
projet de loi on a pas mal de sujets
d'ailleurs la loi climat la lutte contre
le tout béton les aides et feux on voit
qu'il faut encore convaincre les gens et
toutes les questions aussi sociales on
se base sur la question de du pouvoir
d'achat également aujourd'hui il faut
donner des moyens aux gens pour acheter
aussi de qualité pour s'alimenter en
fait il faut que le bio ça devienne plus
quelque chose pour les riches il faut
que ça soit accessible à tous et ça
c'est des questions qu'on porte bon eh
ben cette ambitieux comme comme
programme vous restez avec moi Cyrielle
châtelain c'est l'heure d'accueillir les
parties pris les affranchis ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite la féministe les haches en
Boncelles les journalistes fondatrices
du podcast popol et Thomas l'estavel
bonsoir vous nous parlez ce soir d'une
innovation anglaise britannique on verra
ce qu'il en est on commence avec vous
Léa avis de recherche je le disais où
est passé cette proposition de loi qui
devait inscrire l'IVG dans la
Constitution le 8 mars dernier lors de
l'hommage à Gisèle Halimi Emmanuel
Macron promettait de préparer un projet
de loi où on est temps et bien nulle
part nous dit la sénatrice socialisme
Laurence Rossignol qui avec d'autres
femmes parlementaires comme la députée
et les films
viennent d'interpeller le chef de l'État
pour je cite l'exhorter à agir et à
cesser de procrastiner figurez-vous en
effet côté exécutif cela fait 15
semaines que c'est totalement silence
radio alors que les parlementaires ont
trouvé un accord pour
constitutionnaliser ce droit une
proposition de loi présentée par
Mathilde pano a été adopté ici même à
l'Assemblée nationale en novembre 2022
et le Sénat a également adopté une
version un petit peu remaniée du texte
en février dernier mais bon sommes-nous
surprise de ce silence et bien non pas
tout à fait car Emmanuel Macron semble
être un peu coutumier du fait étant
donné qu'il avait déjà émis le souhait
d'inscrire ce droit à l'avortement dans
un texte à valeur supra lég alors que la
France présidait l'Union européenne
c'était en janvier dernier au Parlement
européen là où il avait prononcé ces
mots devant Roberta metzola qui était la
présidente antichoi d’institution alors
fraîchement élue je cite je souhaite que
nous puissions actualiser la Charte des
droits fondamentaux de l'Union
européenne notamment pour être plus
explicite sur la reconnaissance du droit
à l'avortement que s'est-il passé après
cette annonce réponse à rien voilà après
c'est plus compliqué pour au niveau
européen convaincre l'ensemble des États
membres oui effectivement allez ça
décharge laissons lui effectivement le
bénéfice du doute mais peut-être que
c'est pour cette raison d'ailleurs que
le chef de l'État a préféré porter ce
projet au niveau national et non plus au
niveau européen mais comment expliquer
quand même ce silence depuis le 8 mars
dernier
pour être tout à fait honnête avec vous
Myriam je dois partager ici mon
inquiétude parce que le Président de la
République a quand même cette facilité à
se montrer soi-disant féministe quand ça
l'arrange il est un peu opportuniste sur
ce créneau par ailleurs il a annoncé que
c'est inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution serait fait via une réforme
constitutionnelle plus globale et étant
donné les forces politiques en ce moment
et la majorité politique toute relative
à l'Assemblée nationale on peut craindre
que cette réforme ne passe pas il y a
pourtant urgence comme en témoigne
d'ailleurs les récentes attaques du
planning familial et les campagnes de
désinformation qui sont menées par les
anti IVG alors ce soir nous avons aussi
de quoi nous inquiéter je voudrais
demander à monsieur le Président de la
République de bien vouloir pour une fois
tenir ses promesses voilà en voilà parti
pris un message au sommet de l'État vous
vous étonnez aussi d'une forme quoi de
d'attentisme sur ce sujet non parce que
c'est hypocrisie on le voit sur d'autres
sujets moi je sais que c'est porté par
des parlementaires de la nups de grande
qualité je sais qu'elles vont
[Musique]
il compte qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et
ben on peut les annuler donc c'est un
peu cette idée de capturer le CO2 alors
le GIEC lui-même ce collectif de
scientifiques qui rédige le fameux
rapport de référence sur le changement
climatique le dit la séquestration de
CO2 fait bien partie des outils qui nous
permettront d'atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 je ne vous sens pas très
emballé alors effectivement Myriam bon
déjà une chose c'est que la captation
carbone c'est joli sur le papier mais
pour l'instant c'est totalement
anecdotique on a seulement quelques
milliers de tonnes de CO2 qui ont été
retirés de l'atmosphère grâce à cette
techno et les besoins c'est 5 à 10
milliards de tonnes chaque année qu'il
faudrait retirer pour respecter les
accords de Paris donc on en est très
très loin alors vous allez me dire
laissons le temps au temps ça va monter
en puissance ok mais les ONG sont assez
sceptiques et moi aussi je dois l'avouer
sur certains procédés
une startup américaine qui s'appelle
running tide qui veut planter des algues
au fond des océans pour stocker le
carbone on a plusieurs scientifiques qui
faisaient partie de cette société qui
ont démissionné car ils s'inquiète sur
l'impact sur la biodiversité et plus
près de chez nous on a en Allemagne ou
aux Pays-Bas des projets mais des fortes
oppositions dériverains qui ne veulent
absolument pas qu'on stocke du CO2 sous
terre près de chez eux il y a pas mal de
résistance des obstacles on l'entend
fournoncer pour vous carrément alors
soyons clairs aucune piste doit être
écartée quand on parle de lutte contre
le réchauffement planétaire mais l'idée
de pouvoir annuler entre guillemets les
émissions de carbone c'est assez
dangereux si on regarde des entreprises
comme Orange ou Holcim qui clanne
qu'elles atteindront le zéro carbone en
misant notamment sur la séquestration de
CO2 on peut s'interroger cette techno
n'a pas encore fait ses preuves et
surtout ça nous donne une impression qui
peut être totalement illusoire qu'on
peut finalement un peu relâcher les
efforts et c'est absolument pas le cas
alors il y a un levier de décarbonation
très simple très efficace vous en avez
parlé ça repose sur nous tous ça
s'appelle la sobriété dans les modes de
vie et triste rappel l'an dernier les
émissions de CO2 d'origine face fossile
ou encore battu un record donc la
captation carbone pourquoi pas ça se
tente mais gare au greenwashing et
surtout attention aux mirage du
solutionnisme technologique ça va vous
plaire vous avez 10 secondes vous avez
pris plein de notes
absolument c'est à dire que c'est
manière de ne pas affronter le sujet et
ne pas changer de modèle et un modèle
qui est extrêmement producteur
d'émissions c'est vrai que le mot
démission résiduelle pour des très
grands pollueurs en fait ce n'est pas ça
la question c'est il faut complètement
changer de modèle c'est pas c'est de
captation qui est résoudra et il faut
affronter la question allez on rejoint
comme promis Valérie Brochard en ce 21
juin bonsoir Valérie vous êtes dans les
jardins de l'Hôtel de lacet quel est le
programme mais quelle est l'ambiance sur
place
[Musique]
Myriam non évidemment je vais pas
chanter on va éviter de faire venir la
pluie ici dans la cour de l'hôtel de
lacet où est organisé la fête de la
musique une fête de la musique qui s'est
voulu très éclectique avec une
programmation très originale voulue par
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
tout a commencé à 18h30 avec un groupe
de swing et là vous l'entendez juste en
face de moi c'est la fanfare les
beautiful people qui met une ambiance de
folie ici dans la cour de la sèche je
vous laisse en profiter quelques
secondes avant de rejoindre des
mélomanes des députés mélomanes et
notamment vous Sébastien Jumel vous êtes
député communiste alors vous êtes là ce
soir pour profiter de la fête de la
musique dites-moi ça change un petit peu
de l'ambiance rock n' roll qu'il y a
souvent dans les missiles
un peu de musique dans ce monde de brut
ça peut pas faire de mal un peu
d'humanité et la musique c'est tout ça
et donc que cette belle initiative de la
Fête de la Musique pousse les murs de
l'Assemblée ça me rend heureux après
vous dire que je préférerais pas être un
diable je vous mentirais mais c'est une
belle initiative qu'il faut saluer les
gens ont l'air bien les gens ont l'air
d'être heureux
posés peut-être que ça ça devrait nous
donner de l'énergie pour les vacances
merci beaucoup merci et puis on vous
laisse profiter évidemment de la fanfare
on va retrouver tout de suite les
musiciens de la batucada je vous en ai
pas parlé mais plus tard à 21h il y aura
une batucada ici aussi dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale bonsoir alors
dites-moi un petit peu est-ce que ça
vous fait quelque chose de jouer ce soir
dans cet endroit emblématique la Maison
du Peuple ce soir bien sûr très fier de
d'ouvrir l'été de faire la fête de la
musique et de faire connaître la culture
brésilienne grâce à Aquarella la plus
vieille école de samba de Paris donc si
on peut partager du sombat du bonheur
c'est tout gagné et alors est-ce que
pour être invité à jouer ce soir dans
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce qu'il a
fallu passer une audition est-ce que
vous avez passé une audition avec la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
notre audition s'est passé il y a 40 ans
à travers un vieil ami qui nous connaît
très bien qui connaît très bien l'école
de samba Aquarella et qui nous a invité
ce soir voilà et bien on vous écoutera
évidemment tout à l'heure Myriam aussi
évidemment et puis vous savez quoi j'ai
envie de vous parler aussi du public
bien sûr nous sommes quelques centaines
de personnes réunies dans l'hôtel enfin
dans la cour de l'Hôtel de la selle
alors il y a des membres du personnel de
l'Assemblée nationale évidemment mais il
y a aussi des citoyens comme vous et moi
qui avaient envie de profiter également
de cette formidable initiative donc
Quentin quand un ne bouge pas dis-moi
est-ce que cette fête de la musique elle
est réussie oui je pense qu'elle est
réussie mais personnellement là je
préfère le deuxième groupe
au premier là vous avez rassemblé
beaucoup de monde et ça c'est plutôt
bien mais c'est pas la première fois toi
que tu fais la fête de la musique non
bah je l'ai fait plusieurs fois pas ici
mais voilà là c'est la première fois que
je la fais ici mais sinon oui je la fais
autre part un peu voilà à plusieurs
endroits alors est-ce que tu fais aussi
parce qu'on aimerait un petit peu que
qui ait de la musique aussi et derrière
toi donc évidemment la fanfare se
prépare parce que j'ai appris que tu
étais aussi danseur
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu fais
exactement comme danse bah j'ai fait 6
ans de classique
et puis là en ce moment je fais du jazz
et je suis un demi à un collège Juvent
le TAC tu sais quoi le mieux c'est que
tu nous fasses une petite démonstration
comme ça Myriam et tous vos invités en
plateau je vous laisse terminer en
musique et en danse
[Musique]
ah génial formidable
c'est formidable waouh attention quand
[Musique]
tu es génial trop mignon merci merci un
immense merci à la génial Valérie
Brochard pour ce moment on y va Cyrielle
châtelain on les rejoint ce soir
merci à vous d'être venu en direct sur
le plateau LCP les affranchis à très
vite c'est la fin de cette émission très
belle fête de la musique et à demain
[Musique]